„Singlewohnung mit Ausblick“ heißt es
in der Anzeige.
Mehr als 20 Mietinteressenten
sind gekommen,
um eine kleine Hinterhofwohnung
zu besichtigen.
Cuan Acar ist einer von ihnen.
Schon seit Monaten sucht er
nach einer neuen Bleibe
und wird auch diesmal wieder enttäuscht.
Der Vermieter verlangt 565 Euro warm
für die Einzimmerwohnung –
und jede Menge Gehaltsnachweise
und Bonitätsauskünfte.
Er wollte so viele Unterlagen,
da denkt man sich auch:
Ich will mir hier keine Villa anmieten.
Das ist einfach nur
ne 30-Quadratmeter-Wohnung –
unverschämt einfach, was hier abgeht.
Vor allem unverschämt teuer.
Der Außendienstmitarbeiter fährt
einen Dienstwagen
und ist fest angestellt – trotzdem muss er
in einer Gartenlaube leben.
Die Gartenlaube gehört einem meiner
besten Freunde hier in Berlin, der meinte:
Du kannst auch da pennen.
Das Wetter ist gut, [du] hast hier alles
und wir gehen sowieso alle zwei Tage
ins Fitnessstudio.
Duschen kannst du da, meinte er.
Hab ich gesagt: Ja ok, cool.
Mache ich so.
Doch nun wird es Herbst und eine Heizung
hat die Gartenlaube nicht.
Also sucht der 27-Jährige weiter,
durchforstet täglich Wohnungsinserate,
besichtigt und bewirbt sich,
kassiert immer wieder Absagen
und ärgert sich über dreiste Vermieter,
die die Lage in Berlin ausnutzen.
Der Eigentümer, der hat dort
Laminat verlegt,
frisch verlegt und die Wände gestrichen.
Und dann kam er mit Rechnungen
und mit Quittungen.
Inoffiziell wollte er von mir knapp
3000 Euro auf die Hand haben,
nur weil er sein Laminat verlegt hat.
Zu dem hab ich dann auch gesagt:
Ich bin zwar verzweifelt,
aber blöd bin ich nicht.
Cuan Acar gibt nicht auf.
Vor Verzweiflung hat er auch schon ein
Kleinanzeigen-Inserat geschaltet,
um sich als seriöser Mieter anzupreisen.
Doch es meldet sich niemand.
Die Kunden von Jennifer Sager haben
es da leichter.
Es sind meist Führungskräfte
ausländischer Firmen,
die nach Berlin ziehen.
Sagers Relocation-Firma sucht ihnen
exklusiv passende Wohnungen heraus
und kümmert sich um alle
nötigen Unterlagen.
Dass die Lage am Wohnungsmarkt
angespannt ist,
merkt auch die Relocation-Maklerin,
denn ihr Kundenkreis hat sich in den
letzten fünf Jahren verändert.
Da sind viele Deutsche dazu gekommen,
die einfach auch aus dem Bundesgebiet
hierherziehen, oder auch Deutsche,
die vielleicht ne Weile im Ausland waren
und zurückkommen und die einfach
selber schon angefangen haben,
zu gucken und einfach feststellen,
sie kriegen keine Rückmeldung.
Und deswegen engagieren die gerne
jemanden, der diesen Job –
und so muss man es heutzutage machen –
für sie übernimmt.
Mindestens eine Million Wohnungen
fehlen deutschlandweit,
besonders in Großstädten wie Berlin.
Hinzu kommt, dass die
Hauptstadtbevölkerung jedes Jahr um
rund 40.000 Menschen anwächst –
der Neubau von Wohnungen kommt da
nicht hinterher.
Berlin-Kreuzberg: eine besonders
beliebte Wohngegend.
Die Mieten haben sich hier in den
vergangenen zehn Jahren verdoppelt.
Trotzdem wollen dutzende Interessenten
eine überteuerte Hinterhofwohnung
besichtigen.
Viele suchen schon sehr lange
und sind frustriert.
Fünfzig Leute und ne ganz
schlechte Wohnung, naja, so ist es.
Immer nur Frustration – überall,
wo man hingeht, dieselben Leute.
Es kann sein, dass ich die ganze
Wohnungssuche abblase
und … keine Ahnung – gut, zu den Eltern
will man nicht mehr ziehen –
aber irgend so ‘ne Sachen
in Kauf nehmen muss.
Auch Cuan Acar musste einiges
in Kauf nehmen.
Nach intensiver Suche hat er aber doch
noch eine Bleibe gefunden –
Altbau, zentral gelegen und mit
zwei großen Zimmern und Balkon.
Einziger Haken: Die Wohnung kostet
mehr als 1000 Euro warm.
Ja, die Hälfte des Gehalts geht drauf ...
aber es ging nicht anders.
Mieten zahlen, die das eigene Budget
deutlich übersteigen –
für viele Wohnungssuchende in Großstädten
ist das der einzige Weg,
ein Dach über dem Kopf zu finden.